Cool. I guess we can just dive right into this then. Dan, Taylor, thanks for coming on today.
Thanks for having me. It's exciting to be able to chat and catch up.
It's been a little while. I guess it hasn't been that long because we saw each other just,
I guess it has been. When was it? Like maybe...
May?
Maybe. I don't know, man. Time is weird.
Yeah, it feels like it's been a long time. But yeah, I appreciate you coming on. So for those
of you who don't know Dan, Dan is a paramedic and we'll get into a little more of his background
shortly. But he's had a pretty cool career in that he's done a lot of work as a medic in,
I guess you could say, like atypical environments. So that's kind of what we're going to talk about
a little bit today. So maybe just start off with Dan, do you want to talk about like how you
got into EMS and working as a medic and then we can get out from the normal 911 operation stuff?
Yeah. I mean, kind of going way back, like I did some volunteer stuff in high school with like
wilderness search and rescue, thought that was kind of interesting. Went to undergrad,
got involved with an ambulance corps, became an EMT, figured out that kind of working on the
ambulance was a lot of fun and started thinking about it as a career. Became a medic in New York,
worked full time on the ambulance for a number of years doing 911 and inter-facility in both urban,
suburban and rural areas, which was pretty cool. I mean, I got a variety of patients,
different transport times. And then through that, some of the agencies I worked for would do
like special event medicine for like triathlons, big concerts, stuff like that. So that was kind
of my first exposure to like working as a pre-hospital provider away from the ambulance
in like a really formal way. And that kind of opened my eyes in a lot and especially working
alongside some really pre-hospital forward physicians in those like special event environments.
So that kind of got me interested and looking for other things we could do. I became a professional
ski patroller and that was a lot of fun. I got to ski and then I also got to start doing like
medicine and like wilderness medicine and working out of a backpack and really thinking about how
the environment creates additional challenges and how we're like resource limited and really trying
to maintain a good quality of patient care in what was at times a challenging environment.
And then that got me kind of into the wilderness medicine world. And then so I started following
like wilderness medical society and attending conferences and additional classes kind of with
that bubble as I was able and then started looking for other things that I could do
to expand my experience to encounter new problems. That brought me to the film world,
the TV and film world, and I was able to work as a set medic first in a couple of kind of wilderness
environments. I volunteered with Team Rubicon and I deployed to Greece and I worked in a refugee camp
there and that was my first exposure to like true humanitarian medicine and the problems,
the challenges, the complexity of dealing with not only those populations but then a foreign
healthcare system, seeing new medications, trying to work with local healthcare providers,
being a patient advocate through an interpreter, like all of these things that were connected in
some ways to stuff that I've done before but didn't necessarily in some cases have formal training in.
And then basically from Greece I kind of kept saying yes to things. I was able to start doing
some teaching in like the wilderness and an austere medicine world. That got me more contacts
and more experience and I was able to learn more through that. Eventually worked offshore in the
oil and gas and commercial fishing industry as a medic in the Gulf of Mexico and Alaska.
Worked with a small NGO and deployed with them a few times in Iraq, Sierra Leone, Mexico, Ukraine,
and yeah, kind of kept attending training, looking for new opportunities, and then growing my network
and through that I was able to learn different skills, step into different roles, and just kind
of try to have fun and you know make the world just a little bit better along the way.
Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah, I want to try to remember to like come back to that idea of
as you do more of this type of stuff, just that network you create and you build for yourself
really opens up a lot of possibilities because I know that was something that I struggled with
early on in like wanting to do like overseas work that you just don't know where to go
and then eventually you wake up one day and like your inbox is just full of opportunities.
You're like oh shit now I have to like now I have to decide like how to prioritize where I want to go.
Yeah, that network also makes it easier when you start getting those opportunities
and you're trying to like vet people or organizations or like you're being asked to go to a country
you've never been to, but if you can just text somebody and be like hey Krista you've worked
here for a year, what can you tell me about X country, right? And that, yeah, that makes the
deployment process and even the work on the ground is like so much smoother and safer and
more comfortable in a lot of ways. Yeah, for sure. And then what do you, well before we talk about
what you're doing right now, what were you doing up until just a few weeks ago? Yeah, so basically
the last year, so I have a pretty strong history working in Ukraine. I spent most of 2019 there,
most of 2022 after the full-scale invasion, some of 23, and then from April of 2024 until,
yeah, just a few weeks ago I was working in Ukraine. So most kind of the last like two,
three roles I had were all clinical. The last one I was working for a defense contractor,
a U.S. company. I was their medic and they have some foreign personnel in country doing kind of
like an advise, assist, and a company sort of mission. So I was their medic. And then immediately
before that I was working very close to the front lines doing patient care, a mix of role two,
which is more like a level two trauma center, like similar equivalency. And then working in
medevac, which technically like it's a medical evacuation. And maybe we can talk about it a little
bit more, but it was a little bit closer to critical care transport because we're taking patients that
are pretty sick. They've just come out of the operating theater and now we need to move them to
a higher level of care. And that was one of the places where I really started thinking about
this conversation. And then I also spent time working at a stabilization point, which is,
it's a fixed facility, but it's very small. It can accommodate one critical patient at a time,
and then a couple of like greens and yellows. They're typically staffed. The ones I was,
the one I was in and similar size are typically staffed by four people. You'll have a physician
or a provider. I filled in that role as an advanced practice paramedic, combat medic,
and then usually two Ukrainian soldiers who have like some degree of basic trauma, T-triple C
training, but they're not considered healthcare providers. And so that facility was
underground. It was fairly close to the front because we had to be, because we were the first
people to receive some of these casualties. So we needed to be able to make, to be close enough to
make a difference in some of those cases. And we would do temporary stabilization and then
very quickly evacuate them to the next level of care, which would be kind of the more of a proper
role one, which is like a maybe level three trauma center. And then a role two is more like
a level two trauma center. And I think I remember not too long ago, Corum had a podcast out talking
with someone who's done a lot of work over in Ukraine, and they kind of talked through like
disambiguating all of these terms because there's like, yeah, it varies a little bit on the context.
But if anyone is interested in that, I'll see if I can track that down and put a link in.
Yeah, the role terminology is US military and NATO. So and I've never served in the military. I've
worked for the US military and I've done training for other militaries. So I've learned a lot of
this stuff as I've gone, but yeah, so just for the terminology, and Corum's a great resource for
not only the podcast, but for training in general.
Yeah. And you've also you've been on the Corum podcast before, if I remember, right?
Yes. Yeah. Yeah, I think two years ago, I talked about kind of like the first,
I talked about most of the stuff I did in Ukraine in 2022, and a bit more detail.
Right on. Awesome. And then what about now, because you recently had a big transition,
I guess you could say. So where are you at these days?
Yeah. So now I'm in North Carolina. I just moved back to the US and took a full time job. I work for
private organization that does disaster response with a focus on the Caribbean, Central America,
and the South Pacific. And I'm part of our forward response team. So we respond very quickly.
One were invited. So my role now is a mix of medicine, rescue, logistics, communications,
a little security, some water sanitation and hygiene. But I'm kind of a disaster
generalist with a focus on natural disasters. Awesome. Yeah. And like that breadth of
experience is kind of why I thought it'd be good for us to chat. So a little bit of a disclaimer
here is that this is actually Dan's idea. Dan has done a lot of like, I guess you could say,
like public facing stuff. He's like taught at conferences and like, been on a number of
podcasts, I think there's been more than one, correct? Yeah. Yeah. There's been a couple. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not very good at self promotion, but I've done a couple.
But he had asked me this last year to, if I'd be interested in presenting with him
at a conference. So we kind of like put this concept together, but it never quite panned out.
But I thought it might be a good idea to just chat about these things here. So the initial concept
was like discussing like how you can use paramedics and specifically like paramedics who are trained
in like the critical care transport side of things, like how you can use them as an asset or a force
multiplier in more austere settings, like whether that's humanitarian response or like embedding
with the military for like conflict response or things like that. So yeah, that's kind of why
we decided to have a chat today since we missed the opportunity on that conference.
Yeah. I mean, you, you're a great example as well, right? From Haiti to Ukraine to Gaza to Mexico. I
mean, you've, you have this incredibly high level of training and experience and you do like very
traditional critical care stuff, right? And then you also go to these sometimes horrific places and
employ those skills. And that was, yeah, that was part of what kind of made me think about it. And
it was also, I was looking at some of the patients and some of the equipment that I was encountering
in the role too in the medevac and thinking, you know, it would be really great if I had an adult
like Ryan here to be able to, you know, help and reassure me. And because like you've, you've
legitimately done a lot more critical care than I have. Like I've passed the exam. Like I know some
stuff. I can look things up. I know where resources are, but that doesn't account or that doesn't
fully address the lack of like direct experience and real high quality mentors. So I think like
someone with your background is an incredible resource in these types of environments.
Yeah. And I think that's one thing that we'll probably like touch on later is that
there's, you're never gonna, there's no one person who like has the breadth of experience to like
make or break a response like in this general scene. So like team composition is like a
huge component of it. So if you have folks with like, you know, like different types of experience
in this like general, like paramedic or paramedic center, critical care transport realm,
and you could bring them together, I think there's a lot of value there. So, you know, like someone in
my exit, like for me, for example, like I have a lot of experience in like, you know, like very
acute critical care transport, but maybe less so in like the operation side of like working in
specific environments. So yeah, it's like, I think that was why we decided it would be good idea to
collaborate on this a little bit. Yeah, absolutely. So just maybe to set the stage, what are some,
like, what are some examples? I know you've mentioned some of the work that you've done,
but just in general, like what might be like a good use case for using a critical care
transport clinician or a paramedic? I guess these CCT folks could be like nurses as well,
but someone who has that experience like doing the critical care transport side of things,
like what would be a, like a use case for them in one of these contexts?
Yeah, so I think there's two kind of general cases that I think can be really powerful. So if you have
a gap between surgery and the kind of next highest level of care, if there is no
indigenous critical care transport, there's a real possibility that surgeons could do amazing work.
And then the patient dies during that transport because the vent settings are wrong because the
patient has started to come up from RSI, right? Because there's unrecognized bleeding, like
there's so many things that could go wrong that would negatively alter that patient's outcome.
Because it's one thing, like even in the US emergency medicine as a physician discipline
is relatively young, that is even more so true in other countries. And so then the idea of having
critical care transport ability that is not a physician or an anesthetist is pretty rare
in some places and doesn't even exist in some places. I mean, there's some places where
your regular 911 ambulance person is closer to what we would consider like an EMT or an advanced EMT,
right? So then we take somebody right out of the OR for whether it's operational or patient volume,
for whatever reason, they're not able to convalesce for an extended period, you know, a couple feet
from that operating theater. They need to quickly move from there to somewhere else. And then
from there to somewhere else, that critical care provider can do a really incredible job dealing
with all of those conditions and making sure that the patient does as well as possible moving from
from basically point A to point B. And then I think the caveat with that is that, you know,
pre-hospital people tend to be pretty flexible with equipment, protocols, medications. I mean,
even in the US, like, you know, I've dealt with shortages on benzos or, you know, saline, right?
We're using we're used to having to make some adjustments. And so now if you take that
critical care person and you put them in this, maybe it's a foreign ambulance, different meds,
whatever, as long as you give that person a little bit of time, especially with medications,
if you give that person a little bit of time to read up on the meds that they now have access to,
to play with the ventilator, to play with the pumps, right, to get familiar with that different
equipment, they have the plasticity to be able to say, yeah, you know, event is event. I'll look at
the manual. I'll work through the modes, like, I'll figure out what is proprietary and, you know,
what I'm what I know the concepts of. And then they'll be able to do a great job with that patient,
whereas I think other health care providers or physicians may be much more uncomfortable doing
that. And maybe they still do it. I don't know, like, I don't have any evidence to support if
there would actually be a difference in outcome. But I think everybody is going to be a little bit
more comfortable if somebody who is already more comfortable working in that environment is able to
do it. So that's kind of like the one the first kind of general case. And then the second one is
if we're dealing with things like significant pain management, procedural sedation in a somewhat
low or lower resource environment, where, you know, if if we're going to RSI someone or if we're going
to do procedural sedation, the quality of care needs to be the same, whether we're talking about
an operating theater in sub-Saharan Africa or Ukraine or the US, right, we might have to make
changes. And maybe we use a medication that has a slightly worse side effect profile, right? That
might be the only thing we we have access to, but we're still not going to let that patient desat,
right? We're still going to pre-oxygenate. We're going to do all these things that we are trained
to do to ensure that those patients have the best chance possible. And so if we already know how to
do RSI sedation, if we're already comfortable giving fentanyl or, you know, whatever meds are
talking about, we can take that from a moving vehicle and now move that to a patient care room
in a facility where maybe the alternative, if we're not there pushing those meds, is that the patient
goes through an incredibly painful procedure without pain meds or with Tylenol, you know,
oral or IV Tylenol as the only thing for like wound abridement. And I've seen this firsthand.
But if we have that person that is comfortable with these meds, that is comfortable monitoring
that patient and is comfortable kind of like setting themselves up in a new space,
now you can safely do procedural sedation or RSI or whatever it might be in that environment.
And we have made things a little bit better. So yeah, so I think that's kind of a way to
transition those skills over to that other environment. And especially if we're talking
about the in-hospital, we're taking responsibility for a small part of the patient care, right? I'm
not telling anybody to become a surgeon unless you want to go to medical school and do all that.
But if you have a provider doing a procedure, you can focus on the pain management, the sedation,
the airway, right? You don't have to worry about the leg that's being amputated or is, you know,
they're dealing with the X-fix or wound change or whatever, addressing change. You can just focus on
the pain in the airway. Like we're cool with that because that's something that we do
every day, multiple times a day sometimes, right? Yeah, so there you go. So those are two kind of
general cases that I think make a lot of sense for us. Totally. Yeah, and that first one you
mentioned about just like doing the critical care role or the critical care transport role specifically,
that was something like we realized very quickly in Ukraine, there was like a pretty robust like
911 EMS system, like even before the war, but once there was like this influx of casualties that
needed to get from point A to point B, there was kind of a gap there. Fortunately now,
you know, the war has afforded like the medical system of Ukraine, like the opportunity to like
fill that gap. So like now they don't, there are some niche cases, but for the most part, like
Ukrainian providers can now do that thing that we were doing initially early on.
It's more an issue of just being like generally under resourced.
Yeah, I mean, I was so like I was in the Prokofsk area and we were still, I mean, as of like
February through May, basically of 2025, like there was still, there were some NGOs that are
providing it. There were some Ukrainian medics that had been trained up to a higher level,
but it still, there was this challenge of like some of the military units had great combat
medics that maybe they could do like, you know, push dose fentanyl, push dose ketamine,
but they're stationed at a role one and a patient has just come out of the OR from a damage control
surgery. They're on a vent, they're on a propofol drip. They were also using mandapal in some cases
and they have Atrocurium on board as that was their common, most common paralytic that I saw.
That's not part of TCCC, right? That's not part of, you know, normal combat medicine. Like if you
look at the joint trauma system, there is the in route care guidelines, but that's not TCCC.
That's not what most military medics are learning. So we still had this gap. And now there were a lot
of patients. I mean, some of your simple ortho patients, people that had, you know, rapidly
stopped hemorrhage and then got a transfusion, like those folks absolutely were well within
the wheelhouse for the combat medics. And they did a great job taking those and making the
patients comfortable and doing everything they could. But yeah, it was the sicker kind of like
post-surgical cases that I saw the gap still. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. And I wonder, I guess I'm not
totally sure like how much of that is like that there aren't folks with the training
versus not enough of them. Cause there are some like ambulance services now that are doing like
critical care transport with physicians who have worked pre-hospitally. I just don't think there's
a lot of them. So there still is definitely an need for folks with that skillset in Ukrainian,
even today. Yeah. And it's people also, I mean, people that haven't been to Ukraine also
underestimate like it's how big of a country it is. So if you need to cover that entire front of
the war, you know, and space out some, you know, critical care capabilities between ambulances and
we have these buses that do transports. That's just like a logistics problem. Yeah. Right.
And you can't fly. Oh yeah. Yeah. Flying is bad. Flying is a quick way to have a hard landing.
Yeah. Yeah. And, and to Ukrainian's credit, like there, there had been a couple of a handful of
very dramatic and daring like helicopter rescue missions where they did, and there's some that
came out of Mary Oupil early in the war where they evacuated via helicopter. But yeah, it's not
a viable option. And then especially with the increasing number of drones, like the long range
stuff where in one night you have 500 or 800 large, like car size drones over the country,
you can't even say, Oh, well, we'll just drive them to Kiev and then, you know, put them on a fixed
wing and then take them out. Right. It's just unfortunately not really an option right now.
Yeah, for sure. And then you mentioned the case already of like a critical care transport person
helping with like an RSI or procedural sedation. What are some other like clinical situations,
like not necessarily taking over an entire case, like taking over like the care of a patient from
start to finish. What are some other like ways that these folks could maybe insert themselves
to be clinically useful? Yeah. And so kind of like a lower stress one, and we both did this in
Mexico. If you're dealing with sort of a more primary care type environment, you know, what
like the military would call sick call or like urgent care type cases in a refugee health, like
that sort of setting, the hospital providers were great history takers, were good at vital signs,
were good at recognizing sick versus not sick. Right. So if, you know, if we're looking at a
line of 30 patients that are waiting to be seen, I would take that pre hospital provider and if they
get a bad feeling about somebody, we're going to pull that patient out of line and then try to
figure out what gave the person that bad feeling. Right. I mean, sometimes that's how we're catching
the patients that are borderline septic or, you know, they severe mental illness or electrolyte
issue, septicemia, some of these things that can kind of be slower onset, but that we've encountered
in our various settings before. And in some of these populations, you have folks that they're tough,
like they've had hard lives. They are tough and they are stubborn and they're not going to step
out of line because that would be rude, even if they are having crushing chest pain that radiates
down their arm and write like all of these things like, well, I'll be seen when I'm seen, but that
pre hospital provider can do that. So in that context, we can do triage much like a hospital.
We can do the history taking the vitals. We may be really useful, especially if there's a language
barrier as kind of the first layer of sorting. So if you pair the paramedic, whoever it is with an
interpreter, and so we're collecting this information, we're kind of creating some order within the
chaos that can often work in these places. The physical exam sometimes can be time consuming.
And so if we have somebody maybe with multiple soft tissue problems from some places, you have
issues with bugs, with hygiene, this kind of stuff, you can have a pre hospital provider that
does a really good physical exam in appropriate setting for privacy. And then they can start
flagging things and say, hey, this patient has what looks like a pretty decent sized abscess.
We're going to make note of that. But otherwise, their vitals are great. They don't have a temp.
You know, we think it might be kind of an isolated thing.
Or, you know, we're seeing, you know, this is severe phlebitis. And I am actually seeing a
fever on this patient. So again, we've combined doing a good really basic physical with that
history taking and the vitals. And now we are maybe making a difference in that patient's outcome.
Because in a lot of these settings, the physician level provider, there's often not enough of them.
And so if we can do a really good job and act, not only as a physician extender, but really to help
prioritize and truly triage these folks, that can make things a little bit easier.
We're also, we're used to stocking our own bags, right and restocking. So if you take a
pre-hospital provider and you say, hey, we've got a, you've got multiple boxes of donated medications,
and we have a pen, a cabin, whatever, that's going to be our pharmacy, like we've gone through boxes
and restocked things. And you know, we know that you're supposed to organize things in certain ways,
like, so it's maybe not something we were formally trained to do in a classroom, but
we've all restocked ambulances, you know, all this stuff. And so it's this kind of other thing that,
yeah, we can do. I mean, anybody that's also worked for maybe a more budget ambulance service has
probably had to repair equipment before. You know, so, you know, maybe you're good at troubleshooting,
you know, the life pack 12 or, you know, whatever, whatever stuff. So maybe that's kind of another
thing. Yeah. Now those are all good examples. And in my experience, I don't know if yours is the same,
but I feel like when I first started doing this kind of stuff, the, like filling gaps in like
providers workflow, like always seemed kind of intimidating, like doing the history when I like
didn't know what to do about the diagnosis part or like doing the exam when I like wasn't sure
about the treatment part that that initially when I was like first getting this kind of work was like
a challenge because it, yeah, it feels like very strange. Like you're like, you know, getting in
someone's way or like wasting time. I think there's definitely a way to do it that facilitates a
workflow rather than impeding it. Yeah. But you already mentioned team dynamics and team composition,
right? And I think this is where having the right type of physician provider in the environment
where you guys can sync up beforehand and the pre-hospital, you know, the, the, the pre-hospital
provider, the EMT paramedic can say, Hey, these are, you know, these are the things I'm comfortable
with. I'm thinking I might be able to fill in and help in this way. And then the physician can say,
yes, that's going to be helpful. Or actually, I think it's going to be more helpful if you do
XYZ. I forgot to mention like a 12 lead, right? We're not only talking, always talking trauma.
Sometimes we're talking medical patients. So, you know, if you have somebody like in some of these
settings, we do have 12 leads. They have become smaller, less expensive. And you can get 12 leads
that are standalone from a cardiac monitor, right? So something like lagging a patient that has
cardiac risk factors and maybe has ambiguous symptoms. And then the paramedic throws them on
the 12 lead and then brings them over to the provider. Like that saved everybody a little bit
of time. You know, so yeah, I think it's, it's about kind of knowing yourself, knowing your skills,
and then having a team where you guys can have this kind of open conversation. And I've had
physicians say like, hey, I'm really uncomfortable doing whatever. Because sometimes you get a
physician that has a specialty, but it's been years since they did, you know, family medicine,
women's health, primary care, right? And they say, hey, look, I'm great at urology, but I haven't
seen a PEDS patient in 20 years. All right, cool, man. Like I work on a pediatric critical care
transport, right? I see kids all the time in some cases, right? So you have people that can identify
their strengths and weaknesses. Yeah, it comes down to having that, that team and the dialogue.
For sure. Yeah, it's a good point about the providers themselves being in a setting that
they're not used to, like in a disaster situation. I mean, remember here during COVID, we had like
family med docs, like working in like makeshift ICUs, taking care of, you know, a whole suite of
patients on transport ventilators, basically. So yeah, I think that's a good point. Like where I'm
working now, we have a lot of like local physicians that we work with. They're like the, you know,
the primary ones like providing treatment in the emergency room,
but most of them aren't emergency medicine doctors. Like before the war, they were pediatricians or
family med docs or, you know, like always worked out patients. So that's definitely worth keeping
in mind. And then when some of these places, we also just have like regular, especially if you're
in like a refugee camp type setting, sometimes people just have like regular run-of-the-mill
emergencies, hypoglycemia, you know, seizure disorders, things like that. And that's exactly
the patient that you want a paramedic to deal with because you're out of hospital, they're having a,
you know, sudden onset medical emergency. Cool. Like we can do that all day. So, and that's,
it's going to be a usually outside of like a conflict, it's going to be a small number of
like true emergencies. But when things go sideways like that, you want somebody who's
comfortable dealing with it. So yeah. What about situations in which like you might have to
like do things different than you normally would, like deviate from like pre-existing
clinical expectations? Yeah. So this is one of the places where there are some documents that can
absolutely help us. Because I think, like I said in the beginning, we're not trying to do
cowboy medicine, we're trying to really maintain an appropriate standard of care for our patients.
So things might look a little bit different, but the fundamentals should be the same. So if we look
at the joint trauma system, there are clinical practice guidelines for prolonged field care,
for critical care transport. These are publicly available documents and they will,
granted they are written for the US and kind of NATO audiences. So sometimes they might talk about
specific equipment that's not affordable, or there's an assumption that, you know, a helicopter
is going to be there in 30 minutes and then a C5 is going to be there in an hour. But there is a
lot of good content in there because fundamentally they are considering a more austere environment.
So from an equipment standpoint, like we, you know, capnography is going to be an incredible tool
for a lot of our airway stuff. So if we don't have a proper, you know, a life pack 15, we don't have
a Zoll monitor with the capnography built in, there's a device called an Emma that's this
little thing, it's a little bit bigger than a pulse ox, it goes between your airway device and
your BVM or your vent, and it gives you, depending on the generation, because there's three of them
now, it will give you definitely a, a, a, entitled CO2 number and a respiratory rate. That's the first
generation, the second generation will give you a waveform plus those two, and then the third
generation gives you Bluetooth connectivity so you can, you know, wirelessly connect to that
device and monitor remotely. But so that's a nice little tool where we are still using
capnography to confirm an intubation. It's just going to look a little bit different and we're
going to use, like I know some people still carry color metric, I don't want that, I want real-time
continuous monitoring. I've purchased my own Emma, got a good deal on eBay, it's something that
travels with me, but I think if we are talking about doing professional critical care or critical
care adjacent patient care in these environments, we can bring a tool like an Emma and we can use
that, right? Because we, yeah, I mean, everybody knows how important capnography is in this context.
Again, thinking about smaller devices, we might use a pulse, you know, fingertip pulse oximeter,
much more than something connected to a larger monitor or event, and that might be our primary
pulse ox. You know, with the understanding that you're, in some cases you may have a little bit
of a delay between central circulation and peripheral, that if you have a patient in shock,
you're going to have to deal with decreased perfusion in the fingers. So there are limitations,
but now we can, with some smaller devices, we can still think about appropriately measuring
and monitoring our patients over time. We might look at using like low flow oxygen,
if our ventilator will accept that, because maybe we only have like a portable, like a home type
oxygen concentrator. So now we're running a low flow source, like up to six liters into our event.
So we're still providing oxygen, we are just not providing it from a big tank because that's not
available, or maybe one tank is available, but we're not going to be able to refill it very easily.
So we need to use that pretty sparingly. Some of the equipment, like some of the vents, some of the
monitors might be a little bit older than what we're used to at work, and so then it's kind of
just a matter of pulling out the manual. I mentioned medications before, we may have meds that we are,
maybe we are familiar with the class of medication, like it is a benzo, it's a
depolarizing, paralytic, but the specific drug that we now have in our our ampule
is unfamiliar to us. All right, let's spend a little time, you know, with PubMed or with another
resource. If our local health care providers are familiar with that, we can figure out kind of the
pros and cons of using that. So we can look at our medications and try to figure out what
adjustments we need to make. Maybe there are additional side effects, and so we're thinking
maybe this is something that produces more nausea or more hyper salivation, right, and so we're
going to pair it with another medication that we wouldn't normally have to try to balance that.
I mean, pain management is something that can be difficult, and so maybe rather than just
jumping first to, you know, to a stronger dose of fentanyl, because maybe we have a very limited
supply of that, maybe we are going to try like PO, ibuprofen, and acetaminophen, and see if we can
take the patient's, you know, pain down a little bit with that, or maybe it's going to be IV,
paracetylol, Tylenol. You know, so maybe we're going to try other strategies to manage the pain,
whereas in a, you know, more normal environment, we could say, oh, we'll just, you know,
give enough fentanyl to make them comfortable, and then we'll be at the hospital in 20 minutes, right?
So those are, I think, some of the cases, and again, going back to these clinical practice guidelines,
especially the prolonged field care and the prolonged casualty care guidelines,
have these minimum, better, best recommendations for whether it's airway management, pain management,
wound care, and within these guidelines, there's different procedures, and so they'll say, you know,
the minimum for a wound dressing is X, the better is Y, and then the best is Z. And so if you are
packing, or if you are at a local market or a store buying stuff, you can say, hey, we have a
limited number of the best, so we're going to save that for some specific patient populations, and
but we have a nearly infinite supply of the minimum. Fantastic. Let's use that, you know,
in abundance and as appropriate. But we don't have to make that improvisation and that judgment call
in the moment. We can look at these guidelines and make good decisions in advance, understanding those
guidelines are written by both physicians and people with significant field experience, and in
some cases researchers as well, so that we are combining our understanding of the operational
environment, the equipment that we have available, and then these external resources to help us
modify our care in really logical and sustainable ways. Yeah, that's awesome.
So we talked a fair amount a bit about like how it might look in a clinical setting, so I think
that's fairly clear, but like how does one, because somebody's interested in this, somebody's
listening to me like, this sounds awesome, like how do I do that? Because you and I both mentioned
that like it's not as easy as just like signing up and going, like how does the process work for
like finding these opportunities and like getting into this sort of thing? Yeah, so I think
so. So like one, so like some folks, if folks are already in the military, they may have already
gotten some of the medical training, especially on like the special operations side, that sets them
up really well to work in these environments. For other folks, like we can develop the
knowledge and the skills incrementally. So I mentioned part of my backstory was special event
medicine. So if you have access to that in your area, if you can work, you know, major sporting
events, NASCAR, you know, Burning Man, you know, EDC, the big electronic music festival, if you
can work some of these big events, a lot of that patient care is going to be treat and release on
site, you're going to be working alongside physicians and NPS and PAs. And that may be kind
of one avenue to start getting experience and potentially networking. And it may also, depending
on your, your employer, they may be willing to send you to some additional training. I think I
mean, if you have a part time job at an urgent care, like, that's probably pretty useful,
especially if you have a team there that will let you learn more that will, you know, show you
other procedures, I mean, even just basic wound care, you know, an incision and draining for an
abscess, placing a Foley, like these are things that we don't normally do in an ambulance setting
that are super useful in either extended care, you know, prolonged care or some of these,
like refugee health settings. So if you're already working in that urgent care, if you work in an
emergency department, you know, tell, you know, if you have a provider that you're comfortable with,
tell them like, Hey, I really want to go volunteer on these types of missions. Can I learn more in
the ER? And of course, I mean, there's liability, like there's all these other considerations, but
that may be a really good step forward. Getting experience is always going to be
useful, especially if it's experience with a mentor, if you're able to join one of the disaster
medical assistance teams, one of the urban search and rescue, you saw our teams, those are all
going to be well established programs, there's a clear barrier for entry, there are ongoing
training, there are experienced personnel, it's part of the federal system, at least as long as
those programs exist. And so that may be a really good way to go from sort of being a street or a
more traditional transport provider to now working in a non transport or a partial transport environment
with personnel that are, that have experience doing the stuff, like the, the USAR teams,
I'm most familiar with them, not as a domestic resource, but as an international film.
I mean, there are several USAR teams that used to deploy to places like Turkey after they have a
massive earthquake or Haiti. And the capability that those teams are able to bring is really,
really remarkable, not only on the medical side, but bringing in, you know, civil engineers and
other types of engineers and communications and all this other stuff. So DMAT and USAR, I think,
would be really, really useful. Look at the Wilderness Medical Society. So they're a professional
organization for wilderness medicine, they have some clinical practice guidelines that are useful.
They also do conferences, they do online classes and lectures. So that's kind of another organization
that has multiple purposes. Social media can certainly be useful. There's a lot of NGOs and
other organizations that will post on Instagram and you can look for the groups that are out there,
you know, do your homework, do your due diligence. You know, the,
the organizations that are doing the most sustainable, in some cases, kind of less exciting
stuff will probably be safer. The folks that are doing the really spicy and at times very interesting
stuff will probably be more risky and you as an individual will have to take on more responsibility
for your well-being and safety and not only during the mission, but also after the fact.
So kind of think about, you know, small versus big organizations when you start looking at folks
but yeah, I mean start small, look towards the wilderness medicine world.
If you already have a big skill in mountain biking, skiing, climbing, there are probably
opportunities, whether it's through like National Ski Patrol or through other groups, to use that
skill in addition to your medicine to support expeditions. I mean, a lot of that's going to
be volunteer, but that gets you thinking about, you know, I have an 80 liter backpack, I need to
be able to provide this level of patient care. I also need to carry this amount of water, food,
my own sleeping bed, right? So now you are thinking about mission planning and logistics and you're
also now thinking about, well, how do we get this patient out if we have a problem? So now you're
thinking about the different ways we can do that and the manpower and the evacuation resources,
right? So yeah, but you would, to do a lot of the expedition stuff, you need the underlying
outdoor skills, whether it be mountaineering or mountain biking or whatever, right? To be able
to function in that environment and then you're going to add medicine onto that. So yeah, I mean
kind of follow your interests and if you already know somebody in your community, maybe it's, you
know, a paramedic who works part-time, you know, at your ambulance service or maybe there's a physician
in your area who's part of a Wilderness Medicine Fellowship, like reach out to them and see if they
have a lead. Ultramarathons are another place where it can be an easy step into getting some
experience because most ultramarathons will have some degree of medical support. Maybe it's BLS,
maybe it's more sophisticated, but you'll do a lot of foot care and honestly that's pretty useful
to learn how to do because when people's feet are in bad shape, like the rest of them follows pretty
quickly. So yeah, and then that also gets you thinking about, you know, limited resources and
evacuation and all that kind of stuff. And then one other thing worth mentioning is there are
many, many, many like NGOs or nonprofits that do like international missions. So they like
put a team together to go to whatever country or whatever part of the country to go do medical
support just in general for a specific thing. So that's kind of how like I kind of like edged my
way into this space was just going online and like picking a place I wanted to go and seeing like who
was working there and just sending blind emails and seeing what took. Absolutely. Yeah. What about
classes? Like are there any like specific forces you could take? Yeah, 100%. So I mentioned the
Wilderness Medical Society already, they do two conferences every year. Those, you know, they'll
have a variety of topics focused on care outside of the hospital from, you know, you know, from
like mountain biking injuries that are an hour from a level one, all the way to, you know, diving
expeditions and things like that. And they'll have pre-conference, you know, workshops that are more
hands on. So look at those. And then, like, there's a there's a program called steer emergency care
that I really quite like I've I'm not a instructor for it. I've guest lectured on a couple courses.
That program so AEC is a is a standard and then it is implemented by a number of different
organizations. But steer emergency care is designed for professional responders people EMT or higher
who will be working in an austere environment or remote environment. So that's everything from
people on a search and rescue team, ski patrol, offshore medics, certainly like any folks doing
like high threat, you know, type medicine. And it's really looking at how do we plan for and treat
casualties over a longer period of and doing it in a really smart way. And it's it was created
by the folks who created the prolonged field care collective and wrote the literally wrote the book
on prolonged field care, the the PFC CPGs. So austere emergency care, you can just search for that.
There's a organization that I do teach for so like disclosure, anyone not ready,
they're based in Colorado and Colorado Springs. I think they're an awesome group. They're cool
people. They a number of their folks have been over to Ukraine multiple times doing some really
high value teaching. So check them out. They can also do some like custom courses if your
organization wants to like bring them in. There's ragged edge solutions that also teaches AEC and
then they will do some private courses as well. So you can do a search for them and see where
they're at. We mentioned earlier the College of Remote and Offshore Medicine. I'm definitely a
big fan of their stuff. I know they have some online courses and then some in person ones as
well. And they also deliver the AEC program. They're quite good. They have they're probably one of the
most international organizations, training providers that I know of that they have
instructors from South Africa, Australia, Poland, Ireland, the US. So they end up so co-rom ends up
bringing together a lot of different perspectives. And then they they do some courses in the EU and
then elsewhere in the world as well. So check them out. So I don't have a firsthand experience with
the next two, but I know they have a really good reputation. So there's SOA Rescue SOAR.
So in particular, they have an extended austere provider course and then technical austere
medical evacuation or TAME. Those two courses, I think they're both a week long and they both
have a little bit different focus. But SOAR has a really good reputation. I've met most of their
folks at a few conferences and both of those courses help set you up to provide patient care
in a more austere environment with with the understanding that you are carrying drugs,
you're carrying vents, you're doing a higher level of patient care. And then the final one I'll
mention, European Medics has just started organizing some training. They have something
called the Tactical Clinical Operations course that seems, and I have no financial affiliation
and I haven't taken this course, but it seems very similar to some of the trauma care that I've done
in terms of like working in these military like role one, zero point five type like forward
stabilization point areas. And so I think that would be a really useful course because it's a
higher level of care than your average like tactical medic course. But it's also not like
advanced trauma life support, which is focused on very much a well resourced in hospital
setting. So I think the TCO program from European Medics is going to be good.
And I know they're an organization that has really made an effort to rapidly seek input,
especially from people in Ukraine, but from elsewhere to continually kind of evolve and push
their content from social media to the stuff that they release on their Patreon
to basically just evolve pretty fast. Because that can be a challenging process for organizations.
What about like something non-medical? What do you think about heat training?
Yeah, so heat. Yeah, so absolutely. So it's good to think about the non-medical training. So heat or
hazardous environment awareness training, there's multiple different providers. So heat is a pretty
standard term. And then there are multiple training providers that will offer this.
Some courses will be a little bit more focused on either one geographic area or one threat profile.
And then other ones will be a little bit more of like a shotgun approach, depending on who the
primary clients are. I think a heat course can be really useful. It's going to cover a pretty wide
range of stuff from like using a radio, which you're already familiar with, but then also like
if you're approaching a checkpoint with armed, non-uniformed personnel, how do you deal with that?
Because that's a real thing that we encounter not only in conflict environments, but in some
semi unstable non-conflict places as well. How do you deal with attempted kidnapping or kidnapping?
What's your conduct after capture? How do you deal with communications planning? You're creating a
PACE plan. Most heat courses will cover a little bit of first aid as well, usually like stop the
bleed and a little bit more. But even if you already know, kind of gets and all that stuff,
getting reps in is always good and then doing it in a stressed environment, doing it with team
members who may have a much lower level of medical training. Like I think there's really high value
in that. So yeah, I think a heat or a heist course, both of those can be really useful.
Do your due diligence at the companies, try to find reviews on them. Even if you are just
searching on Reddit and you have a company in name, throw the company name on Reddit and see if
anybody's talking about it. If you are a journalist, there are some organizations that do training
for journalists that are going to be going into conflict environments. So kind of look for that.
And then I mean other non-medical stuff, like depending on where you want to work, if you
are able to take, you know, maybe it's swift water awareness, maybe it's basic rope rescue,
like there are some of these rescue things that even if you are not planning to effect a technical
rescue, maybe that is something to get yourself out of trouble or to, you know, self-rescue.
Especially if you are really drawn to the natural disasters and that sort of things.
Like yeah, you might sort of be naked and afraid and kind of alone and need to rely on non-medical
skills to get yourself out. So yeah, I mean time and resources depending, you know, take some of
those additional classes especially, you know, I'm just on the rescue side, if it's training
that is designed for low resource environments. So like on the wildfire, oh and we didn't even
talk about wildfire, there are medical opportunities for employment in the world of
wildland firefighting. So people can get hired as fireline EMTs and paramedics. There's also
REMS team remote extraction module support, is that right? REMS. So there are these other
employment opportunities, but then there are training opportunities, public enrollment training
opportunities for wildfire medicine, for REMS teams, that they're looking at how do you do a
low angle rescue with a basically a small fanny packs worth of rope and hardware, right?
That is probably going to be more applicable to some of these remote and austere environments
than the very traditional like tech rescue, rope rescue one and two where they say, okay,
so we're going to pull the heavy rescue truck up to the building and then we're going to take out
a thousand pounds worth of carabiners and you know 10 mil, 12 mil rope and whatever.
But if you're interested or if you're, especially if you're thinking about like urban
type stuff, you might look more towards security focused training. You might even think about like
hand tool vehicle extrication as another thing. So yeah, I think and you make a really good point
of looking towards non-medical stuff because we could be the best paramedic, slight whatever in
the world, but now we are in a radically different environment that has new challenges and new
problems and so we need additional skills. Yeah, so really think about kind of rounding out
the training you have and if you know language is always a cool thing, right? So if you already
speak a second language, fantastic. If you are good at languages and want to learn, pick up another
language because it's never bad to be able to talk directly with your patients or your co-workers
or whatever and as Americans we typically don't speak another language which is very uncommon in
this world. And what about like all these courses seem super interesting but what if you don't have
any money? Like you can learn languages for free so we'll leave that one aside. But what about some
ways you like self-directed learning because we all know that like folks working on a truck in a
9-1 system aren't generally like rolling in cash. Some ways you could like develop a skill set to
get into the space without like showing out a couple thousand dollars for a course. Yeah,
so there are groups like CO-ROM and I believe the WMS, the World Medical Society, will both do some
like free presentations and lectures. So you know hop on those. If you do have any continuing
education funds, even if it's like two or three hundred bucks a year, that might be enough to
let you go to a conference but not a full like five-day course. Also the clinical practice
guidelines that I mentioned, they are very well written so you can you know go to deployedmedicine.com,
set up your you know your free account there, log in, download the Prolonged Cash D-Care guidelines
and then start looking through. Maybe start with something like hemorrhage control that you are
probably already fairly familiar with and see what they do that's different and then or
airway management or whatever and then start googling between PubMed, between like Khan Academy.
There's some Larry Melek is a physician from Georgia who's got a channel on YouTube.
There are some great resources where if you are looking at this clinical practice guideline and
they're talking about a med or procedure you're unfamiliar with, you can use that as a springboard
to then go find a credible resource and say okay so they're talking about maybe it's doing an
incision and drainage for an abscess. Okay so they talked about that clinical practice guideline.
I'm going to go look on YouTube on PubMed. Family Practice Notebook is another really good resource
and you're going to start learning about that and you're going to see what equipment is required
for it. What are the indications? What are the complications? What are the complications from this?
Now at that point you are not credentialed to do that procedure, right, but you are starting to
understand how these things fit together and now maybe you do have an opportunity because you work
in an ED. Maybe you're an ED tech, something like that. You can say Doc, can I observe the next IND
you do, right, and now you are taking some of the academic stuff that you've kind of gathered on your
downtime and now you're starting to bring it into practice. So I think kind of a hybrid approach
there with with the clinical practice guidelines being a good starting point or the Wilderness
Medical Society's CPGs as well. That's going to be another really useful useful tool. Yeah,
yeah I agree with like the minor procedures thing. I think that is super useful to have like
additional people that can do that kind of stuff. Like yeah, yeah like even like simple sutures like
pulling a toenail, IMDB, like that kind of stuff. Like you can pretty quickly like read up, wanted
to understand what's going on and the next time you see one like take a more active role in like
first observing and then like helping out do one. But I think that kind of stuff is is really helpful.
The other thing that I found really helpful is like getting more comfortable using ultrasound.
So that's something that is really useful in like most of these settings is just
being able to quickly do you know like on the trauma side, knowing how to do a FAST exam
saves a lot of time because in a lot of these places it's just the physicians who can do that
but they also have to do you know they have to manage the whole patient. So if you can
offload that task with like a good degree of certainty that you like know what you're looking
for, I think that's super helpful. And then once you know how to do that it's pretty easy to scale
up. Like if you have access to a machine or you know you know someone who like bought one off of eBay
you can just you know like kind of extend your exam so like you know how to do a FAST.
Like next time after that if the patient's stable like take a look at their heart and after that
like try and find the IBC and just like kind of work up that skill set. I think that's something
that yeah and the price point is only going to come down on those. Like right now you can get a
like a butterfly first generation for like around a thousand bucks, twelve hundred bucks maybe.
And yeah they just get cheaper and cheaper. So and ultrasound's non-invasive so it's something
that you can you can practice on healthy patients. Like the only consumable is the gel and your paper
towels basically right. So it's something that once you get started it's and especially if you
are alongside somebody who is more knowledgeable that's that is a tool and a skill that you can
practice more. And then I mean with the ultrasound like the the diagnostics can be super helpful.
Um IV access. Holy crap. If especially even just from a medical logistic standpoint the cost of an
I.O. needle like an easy I.O. or a talon we're talking like a hundred plus dollars per I.O. needle
right versus pennies for an IV catheter. And if we have somebody who's deep in shock yeah it might
be great to drill them right away but if it takes 10 or 15 seconds longer to find a deeper vein with
the the butterfly or with another ultrasound and then we throw in that 18 because we've now found
a decent vein that was just a lot deeper. Holy crap that is awesome. Um so yeah so like ultrasound
guided IV uh and then I'm not uh I've had minimal training and I'm not comfortable doing that at
a patient but regional blocks so being able to use ultrasound to to effectively deliver pain
management for an entire leg part of a leg the foot hand um that can reduce the amount of your
opioid burden it can reduce a lot of your side effects of of the various pain meds we might have
to give um so for some and I know paramedics that are fantastic with regional blocks um there are
more and more physicians in Ukraine that were were doing regional blocks on a regular basis
um so yeah like that's another awesome tool and then even in the pre-hospital like the normal
pre-hospital environment I wish we did that at all or more um you know your especially like your
elderly patient who maybe already kind of has a soft blood pressure and now we're pretty sure
one or more things I don't know if I could stop their pain without like giving them fentanyl or
morphine like that'd be cool so um yeah so you know 100 ultrasound is a great tool and especially
if you're if you have a service uh that's already deploying it in some way it's really
pretty easy to learn more um and there's some great resources online um uh yeah and and the more
patients you scan the better um even if you don't have a doctor next to you or a skill
somebody who's really skilled with all of these digital ultrasounds you can save the image or the
video uh so if you're scanning somebody at the station and you're you know you're looking for
you know where Morrison's pouch would be if they were bleeding and you're not here if you're seeing
the liver take that scan you know record that video and then take it to somebody you know maybe
it's you know grabbing a dock at the hospital and saying hey you know we're doing training at the
station can you identify what what I'm looking at here right um and that may be kind of a a way to
help you get reps in um it also builds rapport with those providers they're like oh the ambulance
drivers are learning ultrasound whoa okay all right maybe they're not ambulance drivers right
like maybe they know stuff um so yeah so when when we take an active role in our learning and
we express um kind of respect for that knowledge and and trying to gain more uh that can really
help help our relationships with our or their co-workers in other settings for sure okay then
I just have one more one more question for you um what does your process look like for
let's say you've like done all this prep work you found an opportunity and now you're like getting
ready to go what are some like considerations when you're looking to go out on maybe maybe your first
assignment maybe just an assignment in general yeah um I mean if I know somebody on the project
or somebody that's worked in the area or worked on a similar type of of mission I'm probably going
to reach out to them uh and ask for some advice um I'll you know spend a few minutes googling the
country the conflict whatever just trying to get a slightly better understanding of the context of
like what was the country like before this thing happened um you know and then I'm also now
starting to think about like what diseases are endemic to the area do I need additional vaccines
the the CDC's website used to maybe it still does had travel recommendations
um for different places like do you need yellow fever do you need um
uh you know do you need prophylaxis from malaria yeah exactly right so all that kind of stuff um
if I know that we're going to be dealing with a particular patient population um I might like
either do some like kind of reading in the moment or I might you know if I know I'm going to be
dealing with burns uh maybe I'm going to download a couple of like burn textbooks or clinical
practice guidelines with the intent that maybe those get used at the bedside or maybe it's on
the flight over the drive over I'm going to be reviewing some of that stuff um uh and then just
like basic stuff I mean have copies of your passport copies of your driver's license both
you know physical copies and digital um you know consider having a second smartphone
that's unlocked so you can put a local sim in it so you have data and connectivity
if you can afford a garment in reach even a first generation that's going to give you the ability to
text message through the iridium satellite network so it gives you a little bit of redundant
communication and then if you're thinking about satcoms make sure you're not going to a country
like India where satcoms are illegal for civilians um so just kind of be be aware of that um
yeah uh I mean hack a basic trauma kit you know just for yourself if you're going to a conflict
area plus that trauma kit up a bit um if you can get an epi pen or you know something like that
even if you don't have an anaphylactic reacting yourself it's not a bad idea to carry um
carry anther diarrheals uh get a prescription for zofran on dasutron um because sometimes that
happens and it's better when you have anti-emetics um
yeah I mean there's a lot of little stuff like
you'll probably over pack for your first couple of trips that's fine like you'll learn it's going
to be heavy either you'll donate stuff you'll you know whatever um
uh yeah I mean it gets I think it gets easier with time um with time and experience um
what about a med kit so I know I think you and I are pretty similar in that
we have like a lot of our own like kits but normally when you deploy um the assumption is
that like whoever you're working for like they have their medical stock um so you might be asked
to like bring things for donation but are there things that you like to take along yeah so I have
like I have some basic stuff that um yeah so I'll think about it in two ways so if I'm just
thinking about myself providing uh like doing patient assessments um like independent of any
patient care um I have a diagnostics kit that is that I put together that's like the size of a
maybe a football um it's got a blood pressure a manual blood pressure cuff with detachable cuffs
from uh either an infant or a small child up to a large adult um and then the the cuffs just pop
off the gauge it's got my stethoscope um an otoscope uh I have some fluorescein dye for um
fluorescein dye test in the eye I have the light uh for that um I have a small glucometer with
some test strips um a headlamp with some extra batteries uh urinalysis strips um I have uh a
tiny I have a little note pad to write in and then um uh what's a little uh like the NP's little
spiral bound reference book you know the one I'm talking about I think it's actually is it maxwells
I don't know the name of it yeah but so it's a little reference yeah yeah it's got like it's
got you know cranial nerves it's got uh normal pregnancy stuff it's got basic lab values uh
it's got like a small two-page um basic physical exam with like you know key findings so it's a
small little reference I have a braslow tape that I keep in there and um because I don't like dealing
with kids and they're scary when they're sick and a braslow tape makes the math a little bit easier
um so uh yeah that's in the kit uh I feel like there's a couple other I have a pulse ox in there
so like that that kit is fairly compact that will like always go in my day pack um and then if I'm
doing uh like medevac more critical care stuff typical add a fanny pack that's going to be on
my person um I'll have a really good pulse ox in there I'll have my emma clear eye throw a couple
of pairs of nitrile gloves my stethoscope a pair of trauma shears and then when I was working in
Ukraine I had an additional uh tourniquet a little bit of gauze and um uh some wound packing and uh
and um elastic bandages as well um either for the patient or for myself if uh something happened
um and then and that's in addition to like in my pockets I'm always going to have a multi-tool a pen
a flashlight uh uh usually I have the koram field guide either in a pocket or in a backpack I always
have a notepad a sharpie a pen um a headlamp on my person in addition to the headlamp that's in my kit
what else um
um
yeah but so I'm looking at like the basic diagnostics to be able to collect a set of vital
signs to be able to document those vitals um and then uh yeah and then you know the emma if we're
really thinking about a sicker patient um and then depending and like because I've worked in the film
world uh set medics have to provide their own kit and then the production company pays the set
medic a day rate and then they rent the medical kit as well from the set medic so like I have
additional stuff so if I know I'm deploying with a smaller like lower resource NGO like I might bring
like a small backpack that has like trauma supplies if that's going to be appropriate for my environment
um you know yeah I might just try to fill in an anticipated gap with some of that personal stuff
um and then I think redundancy is good like I will usually have a trauma kit in my backpack
a trauma kit or parts of a trauma kit on my person or in my fanny pack um and then maybe something
like uh in my luggage as well um that's you know can be restock or or can be additional
um and that's I I mean I'm a slightly paranoid person so uh yeah the redundancy is is helpful
when I'm worried about things so yeah I think that's probably something we could spend all day
you and I talking about is like how we prep our kits for different different environments yeah
yeah I was just curious um I think that's all the questions I had for you I was curious if you had
anything else that you think was relevant to to mention to folks who are interested in this space
um we're like some people take their interest and now they want to get into it
I mean I think maintain a good sense of humor um
this can be a really difficult space to work in for a variety of reasons like the you know you
go volunteer for somewhere for two weeks it's challenging in good ways and then you go home and
you know that was your two weeks of PTO for the year right and now you're right back onto a 24
I mean there there can be a lot of challenges if you make this into a career sometimes it can be
contract work and that creates a whole nother levels of instability in your life um just try
to maintain a good sense of humor be aware of your own uh like your burnout your mental health
all that kind of stuff try to take care of yourself um in some of these cases you will
and maybe it sounds a bit shady but you'll see the best and worst of humanity um and that can
change you and and I mean I worked 9-1 for multiple years like I I thought I had seen a lot of stuff
um but
the magnitude of some of the things that we deal with and and frankly the hopelessness of some of
the stuff that we deal with um in in these deployed settings can weigh really heavy um
so kind of take care of yourself and also recognize that the the more especially if you
tend towards working in a conflict environment the more you do that the greater the chances are
either that you're going to be hurt or that people you love are going to be killed or hurt um
and that's unfortunately just a fact of life and it's something that you just need to be cognizant
of going into it um and you're not going to be able to save everyone you're not going to be able
to save some of your friends uh you're not going to be able to save a lot of your patients um
because the conditions that created the environment that we're stepping into
are so much bigger than any one person um but having said that we can make things a fraction
of a percent better for one person maybe we teach somebody and that has a positive impact down the
line um so I don't think it's hopeless or pointless um but I think we we kind of need to have really
open eyes um and be really honest about the the situations that we step into because some of them
are truly um pretty massive and and pretty uh pretty awful um also don't be surprised if your
view of the world starts to change pretty radically as you get exposed to other people
cultures countries um problems uh who I am now is very different than who I was
uh 10 years ago or 15 years ago uh for the I think for the better um but uh yeah uh yeah so take care
yourself yeah I agree with all that I think it's a great place to to wrap it up um thanks for
coming on thanks for having me I appreciate it good to see you guys